[موسيقى]
استاد لوسيل احد الملاعب التي احتضنت
مباريات كاس العالم قطر
2022 استضاف الملعب ع مباريات مونديالي
وكانت المباراه الاهم التي جمعت في نهائي
المونديال بين الارجنتين وفرنسا وحسمها
منتخب التانجو لمصلحته وبعد 13 شهرا سيكون
الملعب المونديالي حاضرا خلال النسخه
الجديده من كاس امم اسيا التي تحتضنها قطر
اذ يستضيف الملعب مباراتي الافتتاح
والنهائي يتسع الملعب لاكثر من 80 الف
متفرج سحي تصميمه من تدخل الضوء والظل
الذي يميز مصباح الفنار التقليدي ويعكس
شكله وواجهته انماطا زخرفيه من العصر
الذهبي للفن العربي والاسلامي وتعمل عناصر
التصميم المبتكره بما في ذلك الواجهات
عاليه الاداء والسقف المستدام على الحد من
استهلاك الطاقه كما تضمن تقنيه التبريد
الخارجي للملعب توفير اقصى درجات
[موسيقى]
الراحه